bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de par le web d'où la dernière de
l'année on refait l'actualité politique
et parlementaire 45 minutes aux jo katia
toujours michael est dans l'actualité
cette semaine l'une des conséquences des
résultats des élections régionales
c'est d'une part l'affirmation de la
ligne politique du gouvernement il n'y
aura pas d'inflexions à gauche mais un
plan d'urgence pour lutter contre le
chômage
à droite par contre malgré la victoire
les couteaux sont déjà de sortie
objectif primaire main tendue ou
tactique envie pour 2017 françois
hollande et manuel valls ont jeté des
ponts vers la droite ils veulent une
recomposition politique large peut être
jusqu'à l'union nationale à droite
certains comme jean pierre raffarin se
disent prêts à répondre à l'appel dans
le reste de l'actualité députés
sénateurs ont reçu reçu par manuel valls
pour faire le poids un mois après
l'instauration de l'état d'urgence au
moment même où le conseil d'état se
prononce contre la prolongation de cet
état d'urgence
cette semaine notre invité est thierry
mandon bonjour merci d'être avec nous
est secrétaire d'état chargée de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche alors nous avons une semaine
politique et parlementaire très chargé
pour vous on commence au début nous
commençons donc par un petit rappel
celui des résultats des élections
régionales
voici la nouvelle carte de france des
régions les républicains remportent sept
régions dont l'île de france et la
normandie
après la vague rose de 2010 la gauche
doit cette fois se contenter de cinq
régions pas de victoire pour le front
national
malgré cet échec le fn singh son record
historique aux longues de suffrages 4
oui michael et lundi c'est parti avec un
appel au changement général
les élections régionales ont donc sonné
comme un avertissement les français
veulent du changement et vite
au parti socialiste des voix s'élèvent
pour demander une inflexion de la
politique du gouvernement
céline martel au lendemain des élections
régionales le parti socialiste réunisse
et hier soir son bureau national
un seul débat à l'ordre du jour quelle
ligne adoptée pour reconquérir les
français
le premier secrétaire jean christophe
cambadélis réclamé plus d'efforts pour
lutter contre la précarité
pour martine aubry la priorité c'est
l'emploi
je pense que s'il y avait eu des
résultats en matière d'emploi toutes les
angoisses des français les colleurs même
face à la situation n'aurait pas réagi
de la même manière par rapport aux
attentats par rapport aux réfugiés qui à
l'évidence ont joué parce que l'angoissé
était là parce que la colère était là
les députés frondeurs sont venus
rappeler leurs solutions en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat
une vraie politique de pouvoir d'achat
peut encore être menées dans les 18 mois
qui viennent on peut utiliser le levier
fiscal on peut baisser la csg on peut
avoir des effets très rapide sur la
feuille de paie si on décide de le faire
et si on se donne les marges de
manoeuvre donc une chose est parlée
d'inflexion un soir d'élection autre
chose et de faire des vrais choix si on
veut faire des vrais choix nous serons
aux côtés du premier secrétaire et du
gouvernement
le soir même manuel valls et promet des
années sur l'emploi en janvier et un
grand plan pour la formation de la une
des caractéristiques du chômage en
france c'est que cela concerne d'abord
des chômeurs qui ne sont pas qualifiés
donc meriam el ghomri la ministre du
travail est en train de préparer un plan
massif de formation pour les chômeurs en
attendant rue de solférino on tente de
créer l'unité un an et demi avant le
scrutin présidentiel
jean christophe cambadélis souhaité
rassembler les forces de gauche autour
d'un mouvement baptisé alliance
populaire tellement tout le monde
demande des changements de toutes parts
dans l'impression que le gouvernement ne
l'ait ne les entend pas c'est ce qu'il
est sourd à ces appels
non je vous jure
le crois pas que le gouvernement soit
sourd à ces appels la meilleure preuve
c'est que de ce week end le gouvernement
va travailler à fameux nouveau paquet de
mesures en direction de l'emploi et des
chômeurs avec un séminaire exact à
yakassé milliards des ministres consacré
à ce sujet donc il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas de deux tours de piste bien bien
au contraire on rangera me précise en
revanche il ya bien il ya une
orientation précise soit le débat porte
sur un éventuel changement de ligne et
moi je crois pas à cette solution
je crois pas cette solution là d'abord
change pas de ligne au bout de quatre
ans d'un quinquennat des années la ligne
qui a été choisie depuis début elle est
très simple c'est pas que c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est à la fois aux
muscles offre on aide les entreprises et
on en termes de droits sociaux
on conseille d'un certain nombre de
droits à retraite à 60 ans pour les
lobes langagière je rentre dans le
détail on essaie de tenir ces deux et je
pense vraiment que c'est pas cette ligne
là est la bonne
en revanche ça veut pas dire qu'il ya
pas des questions d'efficacité des
politiques publiques vous pouvez avoir
une bonne ligne et finalement les
mesures est trop longue dans leur mise
en oeuvre
c'est le cas c'est le cas c'est
absolument le cap sur un certain nombre
de sujets deuxièmement vous pouvez
solliciter un certain nombre de
partenaires et les interroger sur
l'engagement concret qui le met en
oeuvre
au regard de ces mesures je pense pour
être très directe au patronat est
aujourd'hui sans parler même de
contrepartie mais à son attitude au
moment où la reprise apparaît on va être
1% de croissance cette année
est ce que en termes d'embauché ils
peuvent pas anticiper les choses ils
peuvent pas aller plus vite tu peux pas
prendre quelques risques au moment où la
pression
enfin il ya donc dans la mise en oeuvre
un sujet d'efficacité et pourtant la
réponse à un sujet de ligne c'est un
sujet de de mon point de vue la
machinerie qui est pas assez efficace
j'en reviens à ma question les
françaises qui vous ont dit c'est
peut-être que cette ligne ils
l'apprécient meviane et donc cri de
colère oui alors alors comment vous
répondez ça ne peut pas être qu'un
paquet de mesures pour le chemin c'est
pas possible non mais moi mon sentiment
est
en effet parfaitement raison si on dit
y'a pas de problème de ligne ce que je
crois en tout cas on peut voir une autre
option mais moi je crois qu a pas de
preuve en revanche il ya deux problèmes
ils y apprennent d'efficacité des prix
du public entièrement et un deuxième
problème est un problème de distance des
gouvernants par rapport aux gouvernés ça
ça n'est rien si vous deviez donner ça
veut dire très simplement ça veut dire
que en gros les français qui sont eux
qui ont des difficultés il considère que
tout là-haut ceux qui décident
finalement que ce soit la gauche et la
droite
ils sont trop loin d'eux ils les
écoutent et restant le débat gauche
droite c'est pareil on l'entend ce débat
ça y est c'est parti
et pourquoi parce que justement les
français renvoie la machinerie des
dirigeants un seul paquet qui est très
éloignée de même c'est pour ça que moi
mon sentiment c'est que quelqu'un de
réponse à la situation il est double il
est des mesures renforcées dans leur
mise en oeuvre en matière d'emploi de
chômage parce qu'il ya sujet et en
matière de gouvernance de comportement
des gouvernants et de mode de
gouvernance du pays un changement
profond de notre réputa lors il y en a
qui demande encore plus de changements
on a vu passer derrière nous la photo de
cécile duflot qui veut une coalition de
transformation alors ça vous répondez
vous répondez quoi ça beaucoup que bon
je comprends rien je suis à vous dans la
main c'est dommage je suppose et lui
tend la main pas tant la main d'abord
elle parle que de politique politicienne
non mais c'est pas ça le sujet moi mon
analyse c'est que le sujet c'est
l'efficacité des politiques publiques
voilà et le comportement là la
démocratie même sur notre république
cerexhe cdh duflot saas fee avec ceux
qui sont d'accord sur bien sûr votre
barre mais voilà ce sujet ce n'est pas
de dire ah tiens je viens avec le parti
communiste
et puis ce serait bien que vous nous
écoutez vous preniez nos propositions
comme ça ne serait pas de personne n'y
comprend rien tirer plus efficace tiré
vendredi à plusieurs mois plusieurs
plusieurs mois vous aviez parlé de cette
question des primaires au ps que vous
aviez dit vous étiez plutôt favorable
des prix - est-ce que le résultat de
dimanche dernier met fin définitivement
à cette question ben tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il faut mettre dans votre
corps jouit oui il pose un problème bien
précis on voit que une élection
présidentielle au deuxième tour il ya
deux candidats que non seulement d un
tripartisme réel nous tuera il ya trois
grandes formations politiques qui
peuvent espérer avoir un candidat mais
que dans
mir éléments et deuxième élément qui
ajoute la régionale c'est le changement
fondamental c'est que si les choses se
passent comme ça se passe aujourd'hui il
le front national 3 donner votre réponse
sur cette question des primaires il faut
il faut créer les conditions pour qu'il
passe un premier tour entre de très
nombreux candidats à gauche
s'il ya plusieurs candidats à gauche moi
vous avez de chance que moi mais je
comprends pas ça veut dire très
concrètement que c'est les primaires que
c'est une autre façon de serre peu
importe mais qu'on a intérêt à ce qu'ils
aient moins de candidats possibles à
gauche au 1er tour vous maintenant moi
ce que je pense je pense vous mettez vos
propos de ce qu'on aurait dit je ne sais
pas si on va en parler c'est pas le
moment lendemain d'une élection doit
recommencer la politique politicienne ce
qui est sûr c'est que la gauche doit que
plus rassemblés possible au premier tour
de l'élection le plus rassemblés
possible et que donc il faut organiser
les conditions de ce rassemblement alors
on a vu des courses et quand sako joyeux
un petit peu ce qui se passe du côté de
la droite du côté des républicains
là les couteaux sont sortis reportage
signé quentin calmer et janvier nathalie
kosciusko morizet actuel numéro 2
n'appartiendra plus à la direction du
parti
en cause son opposition à la ligne ni
retrait ni fusion aux élections
régionales croire que le parti se
renforce en s'épurant ses vieilles idées
stalinienne moi je pense que le parti se
renforce en débattant et c'est justement
débat qu'on a besoin au lendemain du
jour au front national a fait son plus
haut score de l'histoire
en tout cas moi je suis très clair je
n'échange pas mes convictions contre une
place des débats ouverts sur la ligne
politique du parti qui doit être discuté
les 13 et 14 février à l'occasion d'un
conseil national depuis ce matin c'est
aussi le bal de la primaire qui s'est
ouvert pour une ou le maire entend
incarner le renouveau quand hervé
mariton plaide pour les valeurs de la
famille restent à trancher
la date de ces élections internes au
parti pour les sarkozystes
il faut avancer l'échéance une
proposition rejetée par françois fillon
et alain juppé priori ya pas de
consensus donc je pense qu'on restera
sur le calendrier mais on en a
effectivement débattu un calendrier de
la primaire crucial pour maintenir
l'entente entre tous les prétendants
avec peut-être ce soir également une
nouvelle candidate
vous voyez l'impact un des primaires de
ce que ça peut avoir sa part ni
d'éclatement du parti je vous avoue
avoir votre sentiment
jean christophe cambadélis a parlé avec
ce changement entre nathalie kosciusko
morizet l'arrivée de laurent wauquiez
comme numéro 2 2 d'un d'une inflexion
frontiste chez les républicains
c'est de dire quoi ce qui veut dire
c'est que le l'enseignement que semble
tirer la majorité des dirigeants deux
des républicains de lancer de la
réflexion régionale c'est qu'il faut
trois teasé la ligne et qu'il faut
finalement que les républicains se
positionne le plus possible de ce qui
est en gros la plateforme de l'extrême
droite vous avez ce sentiment là voici
moi j'ai le sentiment que c'est plus
compliqué ça ce qui se passe et que
d'ailleurs il ya le facteur le plus
important de de ce qui est en train de
se passer chez les républicains et pas
celui qu'on dit il ya de fait trois
scénarios de réactions du corps social
républicain à l'élection régionale
il ya ce qu'on appelle la loyauté je
fais référence à une théorie science
politique américaine peu importe la
loyauté c'est à dire l'appareil qui dit
oui il faut tenir bon il faut même être
un peu plus à droite parce qu'en fait il
ya la voix c'est à dire ceux qui
protestent par rapport à saint malo que
se serait brisé c'est pas la bonne et
est le plus important c'est ce qui se
passe dans les régions autour de trois
candidats régionaux que sont madame
pécresse monsieur estrosi et xavier
bertrand qui est la sortie c'est à dire
que on assiste pour la première fois
dans l'histoire politique à
l'autonomisation politique de grands pas
deux présidents de grandes régions
fraîchement élu comme si eux ils disent
non mais ce qui se passe à paris c'est
pas mon affaire
moi voilà comment je vais faire dans ma
région et une madame pécresse nous
explique sa et monsieur bertrand suggère
monsieur jo c'est mal c'est une mutation
profonde de la vie politique ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire pour la première
fois vous avez des grands élus ces trois
là sont des élus à dimension nationale
qui disent moi je ne fais pas partie de
la scène
al je suis un élu d'une partie du terre
du territoire et ma ligne politique elle
est plus complexe
est ce que les débats meba parisien
c'est à dire que finalement il ya une
critique implicite de l'organisation de
la vie politique à droite qui se fait
par la sortie du débat national de
grands leaders nationaux on va y revenir
voir parler de xavier bertrand ce qui se
passe dans les régions mais d'abord on
repart mardi du côté de la gauche avec
des questions sur une éventuelle
recomposition les appels pour refonder
le parti socialiste se multiplient le
rêve d'une grande alliance populaire
unissant toutes les forces de gauche sur
un projet commun refait surface
explications avec jean baptiste daoulas
le patron du ps a lancé hier un appel
solennel aux électeurs et aux partis de
gauche dépasser le vieux parti
socialiste avec une grande alliance
populaire
celle ci aura vocation à fixer une base
des échéances une perspective qui sera
celle que nous appelons dans notre
vocabulaire d'un nouvel epinay c'est à
dire la substitution au parti socialiste
d'une formation politique rassemblant
tous ceux qui ont participé à l'alliance
populaire mais à quel partenaire le ps
peut-il s'ouvrir à gauche
pour les communistes et les écologistes
il y à un préalable changer la politique
du gouvernement
pourquoi la gauche est éparpillé parce
que la politique qui est conduite par
manuel valls n'est pas une politique qui
peut rassembler la gauche
on peut faire un choix qui est celui de
dire on change rien on continue de dire
même maintenant de toute façon c'est non
seulement la pensée unique mais c'est le
parti unique et ceux qui sont pas
d'accord on les ignore et on les regarde
pas c'est pour ça que j'ai fait ce choix
de dire où nous sommes disponibles
difficile encore d'imaginer à quel
concession le parti socialiste est prêt
pour retrouver des alliés au sein même
du ps certains demandent une vraie
refondation idéologique
si la structuration de la gauche est
indispensable il ne faut pas que le
parti socialiste où l'alliance populaire
se résume à une machine électorale
face à la montée du fn une alliance des
forces de gauche
dès le premier tour semble aujourd'hui
indispensable pour ne pas être éliminés
en 2017
voilà on tirait mandri est petite
musique qui monte et chacun y va de son
idée avec même une union nationale
gauche droite certains y voient un
projet machiavélique pour éliminer le
front national
vous vous dites quoi est ce que c'est le
bon moment de faire ça ce que c'est
possible dit quoi mr moi je pense qu'il
faut pas s'occuper de la cuisine on s'en
occupe trop après cette élection faut
s'occuper du menu qui sont ces deux là
qui bat général débat politique
essentiellement est ce que la gauche
qu'est ce que la gauche doit faire avec
la droite à l'intérieur de la gauche
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait avec y pas tous
à excuser moi en france et manuel valls
qui aimait s'asseoir à t'annoncer août
n'en est pas du tout mis ça sur la table
eux ils ont dit et ils ont raison il ya
pour une d'efficacité des politiques
publiques on prend l'emploi par exemple
on est obligé de reconnaître qu'on n'a
pas de résultats suffisants
s'il ya des bonnes idées ailleurs que
chez nous on est prêt à les entendre et
on est prêt mais travailler avec ceux
qui nous font des propriétés pas de la
cuisine c'est pas recomposer la scène
politique prendre tel parti et le
mélanger avec nous c'est un débat
politique normal qu'on a oublié ces
dernières années qui est à traille qui
doit se faire au par jean christophe
cambadélis quand il parle de bell aliant
est la leur ce populaire hui dans son
île et brad patins du parti socialiste
est fait normal que lui et réfléchissent
mais c'est que c'est quoi le les
propositions concrètes autour desquels
il faut rassembler c'est quoi en termes
de lignes économique c'est en termes de
politique pour l'épauler pour la
jeunesse est convenablement mais c'est
ça le sujet c'est que vous messieurs
c'est pas en prenant des carottes et des
navets vous faites forcément un bon
potage voilà il faut quand même avoir à
l'esprit les ingrédients qui font que
les choses prendront et ses ingrédients
c'est des politiques publiques pour
l'emploi pour la jeunesse pour la
recherche pour l'éducation mais qu'il
faut définir beaucoup plus président de
précisément est beaucoup plus efficace
mais vous dites toutes les bonnes idées
sont bonnes à prendre y compris non à
droite au centre vous pensez à qui pas
je pense que le problème de la vie
politique c'est les certitudes
chacun défend son projet comme s'il
avait la solution miracle pour répondre
le problème du chômage et en même temps
c'est ce que voient les français ça fait
20 ans que des bains professeur miracle
qui produisent des résultats qui sont
tout sauf miraculeux donc un peu plus de
modestie
plus d' écoute de la société découpe des
chercheurs des scientifiques qui
connaissent le sujet des coudes des
autres formations politiques est un peu
plus de fabrique collective des
politiques publiques pour qu'elles
soient plus efficaces syrien
d'engagement dans la vie politique comme
vous dites c'était l'engagement de
françois hollande sur un peu plus de
proportionnelle une petite dose de
proportionnelle à l'assemblée nationale
pour ouvrir justement le champ des
possibles pour tous les partis
politiques visiblement votre au pédalage
ou et mais on n'en est plus à quel que
soit le candidat qui sera désigné
président de la république en 2017 il y
aura deux législatives ensuite et vous
verrez que le la diversité des
représentants élus par le peuple sera
beaucoup plus grande que précisément
c'est pas possible maintenant c'est
possible plus tard c'est ce que vous
dites non ce que je veux dire ce qu'il
ya plus besoin de la proportionnelle
corps aux fenêtres de la diversité dans
l'assemblée nationale aura tout seul
bien sûr il suffit de regarder les
résultats des élections régionales après
on a tout de suite après 2017 oui oui ça
se bat avec le mode de scrutin actuel
lui aurait forcément voudrais pas une
gauche et une droite vous aurez
forcément des élus l'extrême droite ils
sont 2 aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale pour un peu plus de 500
députés
vous en aurez plus la prochaine fois
donc à l'université elle se fait au vu
la structuration de la vie politique en
trois poules
elle va se faire naturellement il y
avait une image symbolique cette semaine
c'est celle de françois hollande et
xavier bertrand ensemble dans nord pas
de calais là c'est un signe quand même
de rapprochement vous parliez tout à
l'heure de prise de distance de la part
des présidents de région ça va être un
marqueur de ce quinquennat de cette
dernière année avant l'élection
préserver ma je pense que la vie
politique française va changer beaucoup
sous deux facteurs premièrement
l'exigence que le peuple a à raison
d'efficacité des politiques publiques et
deuxièmement la régionalisation
je pense qu'on mesure pas aujourd'hui ce
qu'entendent ans l'existence de 13
régions avec des présidents élus au
suffrage universel qui ont des
compétences très importantes on va
modifier dans les équilibres politiques
ou à lotir le pouvoir aujourd'hui dans
les régions à tout à fait mais en tout
cas le pouvoir central et le pouvoir
local et prouve cet équilibre qui
existait depuis des années et pas être
profondément bouffeuse et l'expression
par l'émergence des cessera pas des
barons sepa sepa des barons parce que
vous pouvez pas être baron vous pouvez
de baron d'un espace que vous maîtrisez
là quand vous avez des grandes régions
le nord pas de calais la picardie
l'aquitaine le limousin c'est vous
permettent un marron c'est beaucoup trop
grand pour eux c'est un baron en
revanche pour relation avec le centre
c'est à dire la vie politique parisienne
vont changer et moi je souhaite ces
changements là je pense que la vraie
décongestion de la vie politique la
vraie maturation de la vie politique
elle passe par un nouvel équilibre entre
le terrain et le sang et eau ni va tirer
mon dos je voudrais maintenant vous
faire réagir il ya une autre conséquence
c'est en ile-de-france la des fans de
claude bartolone avec une petite phrase
qui est mal passé regardez ce reportage
on n'a pas le choix
claude bartolone reconduit à la
présidence de l'assemblée
malgré sa défaite aux régionales le
président était bien présent à la
réunion de groupe mais a soigneusement
évité les caméras les députés ps ont
validé son retour au perchoir par
acclamation je crois qu'il est apprécié
comme président de l'assemblée nationale
et ce matin sa présidence n'a pas été
mise en cause par personne à huis clos
devant les députés socialistes claude
bartolone a fait son mea culpa après ses
propos sur la race blanche et valérie
pécresse
une formule mal calibré reconnaît le
président de l'assemblée l'opposition ne
lui pardonnent toujours pas la polémique
et réclame des excuses
personne aujourd'hui ne peut imaginer
qu'ils remontent sur le perchoir comme
si de rien n'était mais dans l'hémicycle
le premier ministre a renouvelé sa
confiance à claude bartolone les
polémiques
elles sont derrière nous claude
bartolone encore dit ce qu'il fallait
dire ce matin sur le sujet il est
président de l'assemblée nationale et
moi je veux ici répété une nouvelle fois
mon soutien et ma confiance en claude
bartolone confirmé au perchoir claude
bartolone reste discret absent des
questions au gouvernement pour raisons
de santé selon son entourage c'est
laurence dumont
la première vice-présidente de
l'assemblée qui le remplace il devrait
revenir à l'assemblée en janvier claude
bartolone scab l'un des personnages à
très important de la vème république
tout cas sur les institutions tant que
président de l'international il soit
très très abîmée de cette élection
ah bah il a perdu la région plus que ça
encore non non il est président des
relations nationales qui est désigné par
les députés
il ya une majorité de députés qui
considère que le fait qu'il ait perdu la
région ne doit pas l'empêcher de
continuer à présider l'assemblée
nationale de l'envoyer vers elles sont
adroits en revanche en
lui-même l'a dit les derniers jours de
la campagne en ile de france c'était pas
terrible c'est pas ça que les français
veulent les causes de cette petite
phrase sur la race blanche ça je peux
pas faire cette analyse là je suis pas
certain qu'elle ait beaucoup servi cette
phrase mais c'est sûr que les campagnes
électorales c'est ça doit se passer sur
des échanges programmatique quelles
propositions pour les transports en ile
de france laïque et les enjeux des
débats latence
c'est très bien mais faut pas le faire
alors revenons justement coeur des ctt
et parlementaire puisque cette semaine
c'était aussi la fin d'un marathon
budgétaire de 3 mois
les députés ont intégré notamment les
crédits destinés à renforcer les
services de sécurité 750 millions
d'euros supplémentaires alloués à la
lutte contre le terrorisme comme l'a
promis françois hollande ce budget pour
2016 contient aussi des baisses d'impôts
pour des millions de foyers
thierry mandon des moyens
supplémentaires pour la police la
gendarmerie la justice les douanes mais
pas d'autres économies sur d'autres
administrations
quelle est la formule magique pour que
tout cela tienne sans que le déficit
s'aggrave
je pense que la l'ambitieux oui c'est si
vous avez vous avez raison d'abord il ya
des dépenses à caractère exceptionnel à
l'évidence en matière de sécurité de
lutte contre le terrorisme n'est pas
dans une période où il faut mettre un
peu plus d'argent mission un peu plus de
flammes mais en une période où on a des
dangers nouveau et où donc il faut qu'en
termes de politiques publiques
on avance un nouveau paradigme c'est à
dire une nouvelle façon de protéger les
français et ça ça passe par de
l'investissement s'est pas seulement des
règles l'état d'urgence mais c'est aussi
de l'investissement pour sécuriser les
lieux de transport pourrait plus plus
efficace en matière de prévention dont
les dépenses lourdes celle là il faut
les faire et d'ailleurs il a été dit
tenir dans la durée
elles doivent s'inscrire dans la durée
c'est à nouveau ces dérives nouvelle
façon structurelle exactement adapté aux
nouveaux risques et celle là y compris
si elle passe par budgétairement
ddd de relâchement sur ces dépenses-là
par rapport au budget le président de la
république lui même l'a dit le pacte de
sécurité
ses supérieurs donc l'europe l'acceptent
et le rap l'acceptent parce qu on est
vraiment structurellement c'est pas un
prennent français c'est nouveau risque
nouvelle stratégie de réponse publique
nouveaux investissements vont pas
accepter ça combien de temps parce que
les
déficit avant de donner va falloir les
combler oui mais là on parle de 0,1 pour
cent du pib
on parle pas de deux donc c'est pas donc
c'est pas c'est pas tant celle massive à
dire une puissance publique interne fait
pas des investissements nécessaires pour
protéger ses citoyens
elle est complètement d'ewald est
dévalorisé donc ça c'est pas le propre à
la france tous les pays sont à tubes
ensuite la vous avez raison et que vous
pouvez quand même être cohérent dans la
vie politique
plus de dépenses les baisses d'impôts en
même temps ça fait beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup donc soit comme cette
année on est un peu plus de croissance
que ce à quoi on s'attendait puisque
finalement on va rediriger 1,1 pour cent
de croissance du pays contre 0,7 0,8
qu'on escomptait en début d'année et ça
crée des recettes nouvelles en profiter
aussi pour économiser peut-être cesser
alors là il ya une stratégie ser cette
nouvelle soit tant mieux ça fait baisser
la dette plus soit parce que vous avez
des besoins nouveaux en matière de
sécurité notamment vous les
réinvestissez donc c'est en gros c'est
ça le la stratégie budgétaire mais ça ça
peut pas durer les années donc très
bonne on va passer au mercredi
l'assemblée et le sénat se penche sur
l'état d'urgence mais parlait tout à
l'heure
alors après un peu plus d'un mois
d'instauration de cet état d'urgence
manuel valls a reçu les parlementaires
pour expliquer pour faire un point on
regarde ce reportage de cécile 6 où on
débat juste après éviter des
perquisitions ou des assignations à
résidence abusive le sénat contrôler de
près l'état d'urgence ce matin en
commission des lois les sénateurs font
un premier bilan de cette surveillance
la formation devait communiquer donc
bonnes conditions gouvernement joue
parfaitement jeu coopération du
gouvernement les sénateurs ont aussi les
pouvoirs de 10 youn et des personnalités
qui ont l'obligation de répondre
après françois moulin ce le procureur de
paris et david benichou le magistrat du
pôle antiterroriste
les parlementaires comptent poursuivre
leurs auditions à la rentrée on fera des
auditions donc
des jo mais cela consacré aux
associations qui s'occupent des droits
de l'homme et aux avocats ou des
personnalités qui sont contre l'état
d'urgence enfin la commission compte
éclairer le gouvernement sur ses projets
législatifs à venir grâce à ses travaux
ses réflexions et ses débats c'est en
fonction de ce débat que nous aurons à
apprécier la prorogation éventuelle de
l'état d'urgence au mois de février
prochain est également l'opportunité de
réviser la constitution pour le moment
pas de contrôle commun avec l'assemblée
nationale le palais bourbon exerce aussi
un contrôle de son côté le conseil
d'état s'est prononcé contre la
prolongation de cet état d'urgence en
tout cas sur la durée de six mois est-ce
que selon vous le gouvernement devrait
suivre l'avis du conseil d'état
je suis de son avis est pas aussi net
que ça à quelques nuances près
non mais c'est justement c'est le cepr
est bon il ya deux sujets sur l'état
d'urgence il ya utilité l'état d'urgence
et de ce point de vue là un état
d'urgence à la française c'est à dire
sous contrôle parlementaire comme c'est
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui c'est pas
l'état d'urgence classiques tels qu'on
l'entendait et ça j'insiste beaucoup là
du russe non mais ça c'est très
important parce que le fait que ce soit
utile
on l'a vu sur les perquisitions ça va
plus vite assez cuite et le fait que ce
soit sous contrôle des parlementaires
pour le voir s'il ya des lentilles elle
dérive dans l'application taper sur les
doigts de ceux qui appliquent l'état
d'urgence c'est quand même bien rebonds
ensuite deuxième chose il ya l'idéologie
l'état d'urgence c'est une utilité c'est
dans un moment précis même s'ils ont peu
à peu se prolonger mais enfin c'est dans
un contexte précis dans un moment précis
avec une durée limitée selon des
modalités précises contrôle
parlementaire et avec une durée qui
forcément est limitée est ce que ces
deux mots trop mois quatre mois c'est
l'utilité qui doit dit que vous parlez
vidéo c'est lui qui dira que ça ne peut
pas ça le dira règle voilà si quelqu'un
nous expliquer que c'est génial l'état
d'urgence que c'est tellement bien qu'il
faut que ça continue le plus longtemps
possible
leur marche pas c'est une utilité dans
un moment précis donc moi je sais pas
vous dire personne ne sait vous dire et
d'ailleurs manuel valls lui-même
réfléchit sérieusement à sa quelle est
la durée utile de l'état d'urgence on en
est encore à l'état de la réflexion
on en est sûr tout et je dessine mais ce
qui est très important c'est que ceux
qui décident de l'état d'urgence le
décident parce qu'il est utile et c'est
ce que c'est la routine à l'heure
actuelle à l'évidence il l'est et
derrière les parlementaires que vous
avez vu ici ne nous dise pas qu'il ne
l'est pas mais ce qui est important
c'est ça c'est d'interroger sans arrêt
l'utilité de l'état d'urgence pour
définir combien de temps doit durer pas
dire c'est vraiment bien les cas
d'urgence à nous permettre de contrôler
on fait ce qu'on veut restituer parce
que leur bascule dans l'idéologie de
l'état d'urgence et sarralbe le coup oui
tout le monde à tout le monde une bonne
partie des élus serait content il y
avait une autre composition qui a été
faite celle de la déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux il
semblerait que le gouvernement fasse
marche arrière sur cette question alors
vous que dites vous la mesure ne devrait
pas aller plus loin
bah je crois que le prêt je m'en tiens à
la position du premier ministre qui me
semble très judicieuse il a dit qu'il
faut regarder ça de presse et ce n'était
pas une formule en l'air la proposition
d'aller à la proposition qui a été fait
par le président s'était c'est une piste
qui avait été proposé un parent départ à
droite mais pas que le front national ou
à lui parler par le républicain donc et
le président a dit bah écoutez on va
regarder on va demander au conseil
d'état ce cas là le conseil la passe le
conseil d'état y donne un avis pour le
moins ambiguë cette question peut pas
dire qu'il ya où il s'est très vite
avoir la balle ils nous renvoient la
balle et du premier ministre
jusque là seule chose qui à dire ça date
d'il ya trois jeux deux jours trois
jours à la vie du causse et équilibre on
va regarder ça de près c'est exactement
ce qu'il faut faire parce que vous vous
lancez dans le ja des anges motifs qui
plaide pour en l'occurrence le fait que
des gens qui haïssent la france ne vois
pas pourquoi ils m'ont avoir la
nationalité française et il ya des
difficultés très concrète pas ça veut
pas donner le sentiment
oui mais au delà de la symbolique
politique c'est à dire c'est une
proposition qui vient de la droite a
voulu que ça veut dire oui ça fonctionne
pas forcément mais qu'il ya des gens des
flux d'aidé qui considère que c'est
toujours pareil il ya deux cas il y
aurait deux catégories de français qui
se seraient pas bien donc vous regardez
de près et avant de prendre une décision
il faut être prudent qu'il faut regarder
pragmatisme ont évoqué les questions
économiques les questions de chômage ya
une petite phrase cette semaine qui a
fait un peu de bruit c'est celle de
gérard longuet vous allez l'entendre il
dit que finalement les français soient
un petit peu fédéraux écouter
l'information professionnelle c'est
indispensable ce qui compte le plus
c'est la motivation professionnelle
nous avons des français qui ont des
poils dans la main il faut le savoir
c'est à dire qui c'est trop dur c'est
trop loin c'est pas ce que je veux pour
cordes et moi j'ai été formé pour faire
du théâtre et on me propose de faire du
commercial mais non généralisée
peut-être un tout petit peu pas tant le
char attendant la masse est une formule
qui risque de rester alors c'est une
vérité tous les employeurs qu'ils vous
disent il ya des jeunes qui viennent
pointer chez moi et qui me dit surtout
ne proposait rien j'attends plusieurs
mois avant de que des ministres ceux des
propos qui sont lamentables excusez moi
de vous le dire
il commence sur la motivation ce qui est
un vrai sujet c'est à dire que vous êtes
quoi la motivation c'est simple c'est
quelqu'un qui travaille il doit être
remercié parce qu'il travail rémunéré
comme il convient avoir des perspectives
de carrière et de considérer il ya un
ensemble de padt de deux choses qui vont
avec la motivation donc il commence par
expliquer qu'ils apprennent de de
motivation ce que je crois c'est à dire
que des gens qui travaillent bien sont
pas forcément rémunéré n'ont pas
forcément les carrières commis leurs
mérites ou considérer tout simplement
comme ils le méritent pour terminer par
des les français sont des feignants
battue c'est une farce
d'ailleurs la meilleure solution c'est
évident pourquoi les investissements la
france est un des pays qui attire le
plus d'investissements étrangers depuis
des années c'est pas parce que les les
étrangers les grands groupes
internationaux considèrent que les
français sont des fainéants
c'est au contraire de ce qu'ils
considèrent qu'ils travaillent bien des
cas il ya une question si vous savez
cette fameuse que sur l'assistanat
d'ailleurs je sais pas si on sait pas ce
qu'il dit les français sondés sont des
fainéants cessé totalement ses c'est
faux c'est pas faux idéaux de ces faux
idéologiquement et s'il faut dans les
faits encore une fois les
investissements la france est un des
pays qui accueillent le plus
d'investissements étrangers chaque année
parce que les entreprises étrangères
considère que les français travaillent
bien en revanche moi je trouve qu'à
passe
de d'encouragement financier à
l'investissement professionnel et celle
ci a beaucoup de burnout dans les
entreprises
s'il ya tant de difficultés si si il y à
un preuve de considération et de
motivation financière
c'est très important se considérait
effectivement pas considérés à leur
juste valeur ne le sont pas et là on
revient sur ce qu'on a dit précédemment
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les lieux de
décision déplacer les lieux de décision
dans l'entreprise ou dans le pays ont
passé de considération pour la diversité
de la scène vers le défaut de
considération des individus dont souffre
les individus en général dans le pays
dont souffre la jeunesse de notre pays
que c'est un des grands maux de notre
république et ça veut dire qu'il faut
changer le pouvoir justement c'est à
dire changer le regard de ceux qui
décident sur la réalité de notre société
va justement les temps changent et
notamment dans les régions on parlait de
ce nouveau pouvoir donner aux régions
après sa victoire dans le grand nord
justement xavier bertrand a choisi de
quitter son poste de député maire pour
se consacrer pleinement à sa région
et valérie pécresse a fait de même mais
en revanche certains ont choisi de
rester là où ils sont c'est le cas
notamment de laurent wauquiez à droite
on de jean yves le drian à gauche elsa
monde un gars va nous parle des bons et
mauvais élèves en matière de cumul
regarder il devienne président de
conseil régional
qu'advient-il de leur autre mandat
certains font le choix de se consacrer à
100% à leur région
c'est le cas de xavier bertrand élu en
nord-pas-de-calais picardie
je vais quitter mes fonctions de député
de l'aisne je vais quitter mes fonctions
de maire de saint quentin et pourtant
j'aime ma ville profondément et j'ai
décidé aussi de ne pas être candidat à
la primaire de la droite et du centre
ou encore de valérie pécresse en ile de
france d'autres comme christian estrosi
démissionnent de leur mandat de député
mais conserve des fonctions locales la
présidence de la métropole nice côte
d'azur
et puis certains cumulent c'est le cas
de laurent wauquiez président de la
région rhône alpes auvergne qui reste
député et vient d'être nommé numéro deux
du parti les républicains ou encore jean
yves le drian président de la région
bretagne ministre de la défense
j'ai annoncé aux bretonnes et aux
bretons que si j'étais candidat à la
présidence de la région bretagne c'était
pour lui y rester par ailleurs il ne
vous a pas échappé que la france n est
en état d'urgence et le présent de
répliques a sauté que je reste mais en
défense le temps nécessaire parce que
nous sommes en guerre pour l'instant
députés sénateurs et députés européens
peuvent cumuler leur mandat avec une
fonction exécutive locale
mais à partir de 2017 ils devront
choisir a tellement de vous interroger
sur cette question comme jim jarrassé
qui nous a rejoint le monde du scad
interrogé lui aussi en quelques minutes
avoue katia est d'abord sur xavier
bertrand qui renonce donc à tous ses
mandats et même à la primaire à droite
vous dites chapeau
chapeau oui je dis chapeau à xavier
bertrand et chapeau à valérie pécresse
voilà deux élus et xavier bertrand il
renonce à tout pour s'occuper de sa
région alors qu'il ya quelques semaines
il était maire et même candidat à la
primaire
le cours d'eau de bravo et bravo madame
pécresse de se consacrer à sa région
c'est ça dont les français ont besoin de
gens qui s'engagent en revanche chapeau
dame pour monsieur wauquiez chapou donne
mr dupont aignan et même belga la gauche
madame dégâts pour lé pa lé pas encore
débuté mais non mais non m'évoquer ok
c'est le pire du pire mais non mais
c'est pas parce que non mais il faut
savoir que c'est ya pas plus il est soit
disant jeunes élus politiques c'est le
plus vieux des hommes politiques
français
il est président noyon il est député et
en plus dans la semaine comme si ça
suffisait pas il est maintenant numéro
deux des républicains
enfin je veux dire c'est superman dire
que cet homme ait et d'ailleurs on se
demande pourquoi on fait encore des
élections dans sa région parce que il
suffirait de dire nous on veut évoquer
pour que tous les problèmes soient
réglés ça c'est vraiment de la vieille
politique mais alors et leucate jean
yves le drian qui suscite quelques
interrogations skis et ski tout ça c'est
différent non non mais attendez
la france est en guerre la france a
désarmé engagé il est à la tête du
ministère de la défense depuis le début
du quinquennat
il a lui-même dit que la région il
lâcherait pas voilà et qu' il était à
disposition du président de la
république voire de plomb c'est au
président de la république de choisir le
moment où il peut considérer le sans
aucun risque pour l'engagement de la
france sur les terrains de bataille dans
le monde qui pour les militaires sur les
militaires français
on peut faire un changement de ministre
à faire on voudrait situation
exceptionnelle dans lequel se trouve la
justifie le chef des armées quand on le
remplace il faut être sûr que il n'ya
pas de hiatus est donc le président de
la république réfléchissent au moment où
il faudra tout dans le faire ça me
semble indispensable
on va passer à la loupe du scan tout
fait
bonjour thierry mandon on a fait le
récap de la semaine politique on va
maintenant passer à l'année politique
puisque c'est la dernière émission de
l'année si vous deviez résumer cette
année politique très compliqué en un mot
quel serait-il
et c'est une année charnière au sens où
à la fin de l'année
la donne pour le pays n'a plus rien à
voir avec le début de l'année et en gros
ce moment charnière
c'est d'abord un moment kelly au
terrorisme qui a frappé deux fois en
début d'année et en fin d'année l'homme
et la vie politique la vie démocratique
à la fin de l'année ne peut plus être là
même qu'elle était au début
ok c'est une vraiment une année
charnière de ce produit le génie
politique de l'année selon vous tiens et
mandroux vous pouvez répondre de
françois françois hollande mais vous
pouvez aussi accéder bertreau le génie
politique
vous même vous donner un nom ça me
semble pas ça moi j'aurais plutôt
tendance à dire une réforme je pense que
c'est une belle région
là je les assume pas ce que c'est un
génie pourquoi c'est un génie politique
parce que c'est ça va changer en
profondeur dans la durée pas tout de
suite la vie politique française on va
être obligé de redécouvrir ou de
découvrir ce qu'est une vraie
régionalisation décentralisation du
pouvoir et un équilibre différent entre
l'état central et ceux qui gèrent le
terrain je pense que c'est salutaire
pour notre pays
le mauvais génie politique de l'année
selon vous la boulimie certes pas un
homme la vue basse et si vous voulez un
nom laurent wauquiez c'est à dire ceux
qui sont là aussi écrit en italie mais
non mais c'est pas lui
j'aime être convaincu gens qui se
considèrent tellement indispensable à la
vie du pays qu'il faut qu'ils soient
partout voilà ça c'est bon on n'en veut
plus votre meilleur souvenir politique
de l'année en tant que ministre c'est
matière de simplification
le programme que nous avons annoncées
avec le président de la république
autour d'un certain nombre de grands
changements permis de construire
feuilles de paye qui seront tous en
place à partir du début de l'année
prochaine
votre pire souvenir évidemment en tant
que ministre il ya eu des moments
difficiles dans cette veine 2015 basse
et les attentats de ces dernières
semaines qui ont touché dramatiquement
le secteur dont je m'occupe
l'enseignement supérieur la recherche
puisque on a eu pas loin de 40 victimes
en région parisienne dans les
universités et dans dans la recherche
française ou étudier en erasmus ça a été
un moment d'une douleur extrêmement
profond est ce que vous avez eu un
regret pour cette année 2015 quelque
chose que en tant que ministre vous
auriez aimé
faire ou peut-être pour votre camp
politique oui moi j'ai un regret c'est
que quand je m'occupais de
simplification j'essayais d'alerté tout
le monde sur les dysfonctionnements du
rsi le régime lui a ainsi qui touche les
indépendants j'avais proposé un certain
nombre de mesures de simplification et
qui a rendu ces régimes plus efficace et
j'ai pas été écoutés comme je l'aurais
aimé mais ben ça va être modifié sa non
bah il faut une urgence absolue c'est un
régime qui qui fait beaucoup de mal à
plein de gens alors que dans son idée il
est plutôt il ya une bonne idée qui est
perverti par les conditions de sa mise
en oeuvre
donc il ya quelques progrès qui ont été
faits mais sont à succès comme le
regrette françois hollande à l'époque
quand il avait 10 sur la tva sociale par
exemple qui avait éliminé du jeu après
son élection en 2012 ça fait partie
aussi des regrets du quinquennat non moi
j'en ai un depuis le début du
quinquennat c'est sûr qu'on a été un peu
trop systématique sur la suppression de
régime des heures supplémentaires mais
je l'avais exprimé donc sage et peut
changer la vie
je pense que ç'a eu beaucoup de
conséquences sur les petits salaires
voilà qu'on aurait dû protéger les
indices alors qu'oasis ou bois par par
pas par pas quelque chose qui relève de
la fabrique des politiques vont croître
au maquereau on croit trop aux grandes
idées qui vont tout régler or c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche maintenant je
m'occupe de la recherche je vois des
scientifiques
ils me disent attention regardez très
concrètement que chaque fois que vous
prenez une décision
les conséquences concrètes que ça a sur
le terrain qui sont pas toujours celles
que vous pensez que ça aura et n'hésitez
pas à corriger
au vu des résultats concrets des mesures
que vous ces mesures là pour regarder
dans l'avenir et vers 2010 2016 2016 vos
souhaits pour cette année - une
gouvernance beaucoup plus ouverte
beaucoup moins pyramidal c'est à dire
que les décisions soient prises de
manière beaucoup plus concertée des
collaborer collaborative et par des
niveaux hiérarchiques très diversifiés
plutôt que par la prétention parfois que
telle ou telle à en réunissant deux ou
trois experts des choses de de dire
qu'il est bon pour le pays une promotion
peut-être lors du prochain remaniement
on
on vous a vu parler là de manière très
pertinente en de toute l'actualité
politique
vous étiez un peu en dehors de votre
rôle de ministre
moi je n'en sais rien mais est ce que
vous avez des vues sur peut-être un
poste un autre poste au sein du
gouvernement non non moi j'ai aucune vue
sur rien le maire j'ai commencé à la
simplification
maintenant je m'occupe de l'enseignement
supérieur la recherche ça c'est génial
en revanche j'ai pour ce secteur là
quelques priorités que j'aimerais bien
voir aboutir notamment en matière de
renforcement de l'autonomie de nos
universités et de moyens nouveaux pour
la recherche notamment la recherche
fondamentale
merci beaucoup tu répondes remercier
djimou merci à tous de passer de bonnes
fêtes de fin d'année on se retrouve l'an
prochain même lieu même heure très beau
site programme seules chaînes
parlementaires